SEC has approved Bitcoin ETFs I believe
more than just I think it's crypto
Market ETFs and there's a lot of people
who are concerned about a lot of people
cheering it on but this brings us to uh
the acceptance of the US government as
it pertains to crypto and the fear that
they're going to push Central Bank
digital currency also known as cbdc
could you explain to people what that is
and your position on cbdc sure and and
so let's just take
decentralized decentralized options in
the blockchain like block like big coin
or otherwise put that to one side I
think greater decentralization at least
has an option that's available to hold
the dollar to its feet as an alternative
to opt out from that system as a good
thing let me pause you real quick though
sorry just there's probably a lot of
people who don't know what Central Bank
digital currency even so let me just
let's just so I was going to I was going
to segregate the issue of Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency away from the Central
Bank digital currency which the easiest
way to think about this would be turning
your dollar into effectively a digital
asset that's centrally monitorable we
could use you know talk about which way
they would use the blockchain or not it
doesn't matter the simple way to think
about it is take the cash in your pocket
and convert that into the equivalent of
like tokens you'd get in a digital video
game and they can either up or down the
number of points you have which are
dollars in your bank account not based
on how what you deposit or take in or
take out but based on whatever the
government actually decides is the
criteria for increasing or decreasing
what's in your bank account indeed
they're doing this China in fact that's
one of the principal Arguments for
bringing it to the United States is that
China is adopting a digital Yuan has a
equivalent of a central bank digital
currency in China now we have to ask
ourselves why is China doing it the
general argument in the UK which is
moving in this direction and the US
which is taking the earliest of steps to
move in this direction through the
so-called fed now program the argument
is we have to keep up technologically
with China keep up with the Joneses or
keep up with the Xin pings as the case
may be here right you to ask yourself
why is China doing it they want to
actually be able to exert monitoring and
control and discipline of their own
citizens it's the ultimate manifestation
of a social credit system so that's what
this is about in China now there's a
version of this it wasn't exactly
through a central bank digital currency
per se but to at least understand the
impact it could have on your life look
at what they did to the Canadian
truckers they cut off access to their
bank accounts they cut off access to
their Canadian dollars when they took a
position against vaccine mandates and a
position against lockdowns that they
couldn't address through any means other
than through using the weaponization of
the financial system to do it so if we
bring that Central Bank digital currency
of the United States it offers another
tool for what would be otherwise a
tyrannical permanent government to be
able to more effectively Implement its
will to be clear and some people fall
into this trap of thinking that just
because we eliminate the tool we've
eliminated the intention no the
intentions still exists but that doesn't
mean that you still give them the same
tool that would allow them to more
quickly imp what they already are
looking to in other ways I'd like to uh
elaborate on why this would be so
nightmarish several year uh I mean we're
talking eight or so years ago 10 years
ago we started seeing the rise of social
media censorship if you tweeted
something that was against the popular
narrative you get you'd get suspended
many of us were called conspiracy
theorists for arguing what was actually
happening in fact it was reported by I
believe it was Gizmodo 1 in May of 2016
that Facebook had staff removing
conservative newss Outlets from their
trending tab
that's just your ability to speak I know
one of the more serious things to be
able to to to lose to not be able to
engage in the public sphere imagine the
same scale of censorship but in terms of
you buying milk bread and eggs yes one
day you wake up and you go to the
grocery store and you're using your app
because that's what the Central Bank
digital currency will be forced to be on
your phone and you'll walk up you'll put
your milk on the self checkout because
there's no humans anymore you'll scan
your phone and it'll say you have been
banned from purchasing for 24 hours due
to hate speech or docked a certain
number of dollars by the way just going
back to just bringing up Co and the
things that we saw throughout Co that
was one of my major concerns that I
spoke about uh just the digitization of
everything that was happening at that
time suddenly like they were trying to
say your menus could have potentially
have covid they kept saying that dollar
bills this was do you remember this in
the news dollar bills could spread covid
and suddenly they didn't want any more
dollar bills we're no longer accepting
cash was so many restaurants uh grocery
stores no long cash because you could
potentially spread covid which was an
absurdity in my mind an absolute
absurdity but a lot of these things are
now long lasting right in terms of the
fact that there's not that many human
beings I don't know if it's the same
where you live but not many human beings
at the grocery store anymore they kept
up the things after Co that they said
were just for covid and I felt that it
was very much because they did want us
to move in this direction as Society
well you can see in lasas potentially to
prep us for this and I just want to play
that one step forward to tie earlier to
one of uh an increasingly what looks
like a republican policy uh certainly of
a certain candidate of tying your
government issued ID to your internet
account or your social media account so
now combine that with the Central Bank
digital currency now you don't have to
tie it just milk in the grocery store
every time you hit like on a tweet that
does not match the regime's approved
narrative we could dock you 50 cents if
youit retweet you actually dock you a
dollar and so Jack Smith I just want to
tie this together right right now in The
subpoena for one of the federal cases
against Donald Trump there's so many of
the you lose track but it's one of the
Jackson Smith Federal
prosecutions in that subpoena I think
it's worth people understanding it
certainly affects people who are
watching us right now might affect some
of us in this room maybe some of us at
this table I don't know not me because I
wasn't using Twitter back then but if
you retweeted or liked one of Donald
Trump's posts in that
year that's now the subject of Jack
Smith's subpoena so let's play that
forward that that your your username or
whatever has already been the subject of
that subpoena now say that that handle
was tied to your government issued ID
which is also tied to your digital
dollar he can't convict you in court
necessarily but why don't we give them a
nice little spanking take a few dollars
out of their bank account that's
literally where this vision of the the
so-called great reset that's where this
land that would be a coup that would be
something that would be an attempted
coup by global enforcement Powers uh
that we cannot allow to happen they can
already freeze your bank accounts when
you're under investigation say you
worked for a company and then all of a
sudden one day you can't buy things
but with the Central Bank digital
currency it goes so far beyond that
we're going social credit system but
it's automated yeah it's to where it
won't even be a judge saying I think
there's probable cause to freeze his
account it's going to be a machine
saying your account is frozen and good
luck imagine having to go to the DMV
every time you needed to get your bank
unbanned and this is the I tell me if
this is like too abstract and we can
sort of bring it back but it's a pattern
that repeats itself in so many different
places where right now you're right they
can freeze your your bank account even
as it exists today but it takes
something that requires the government
to take a Quantum step right you have to
have a preponderance of evidence that's
50.1 to con percent chance of actually
having done it and then to actually
convict somebody you have to be Beyond a
reasonable doubt that's 99.999% 100%
certainty so you have to take these
Quantum steps of certainty what the
Central Bank digital currency does is it
takes this system that ties a Quantum
level of certainty and just makes it
continuously varying right right so it's
not like Jack Smith is going to say that
he's going to wipe out your entire bank
account and freeze your entire bank
account the way this would work is I'm
just going to dock You by 50 Cents like
I think that's actually the thing to see
is it wouldn't be if we were using the
analogy Tim I think it would be less
that we're not going to allow you to buy
the milk at all it's going to be that
instead of having $100 you now have 99
so it's designed to change behaviors at
the margin and that's really where this
is different from the current status quo
where they technically could also freeze
your bank account entirely couldn't Buy
bu any milk it's not that it's that you
like to post we didn't quite like we see
that because of your government issued
ID tied to your social media profile
it's not like we need to go to the court
system for that it's not like you've
done something criminal but we're just
going to dock you a little bit with a
little so-called nudge in the right
direction that's actually what's
actually far more frightening but with
the cbdc there's so much more here too
we can't even begin to imagine how about
geol loocking transactions meaning let's
say there is a a political rally
happening in DC and the President says
we're going to have a rally so then
anybody who attends that rally their
their their their ability to transact is
shut off within 50 miles and just these
individuals all of a sudden you can't
buy train tickets you can't buy milk you
can't buy pizza you can't go to the you
can't go to McDonald's to buy food and
for anybody who thinks it's a ridiculous
example I I believe it's Bank of America
that handed over records for anybody who
was in Washington DC on January 6 2021
to Jack Smith which is exactly not that
far from what you're describing today so
but I think it's worth I think for the
people there's a lot L people in New
Hampshire that fit this category when
I'm campaigning there who come up and
ask like this will be the first question
they ask at a town hall is like tell me
about your position on
cbdc I I share why I think it's a risk
but I think it's important not to fall
in the Trap of thinking just because
we've stopped that you still have a
government that can do a lot of these
things to you it's just that it becomes
a lot easier for the government to do
these things to you when they can do it
in small increments rather than Bank of
America having to hand it over to a
prosecutor who needed to go through
probable cause a lot of this can just be
done much more easily so even as we put
the kabash on the cbdc and I will and
that's easy it's just simple executive
action this is never going to happen in
the United States I'll get that done in
January of 2025 a year from now we're
good it's still just you know it's like
a water balloon it's like a hydraulic
pump system you squeeze it here it's
it's going to show up somewhere else and
so we're always kind of one step behind
and the reason people don't pay
attention ESG cbdc whatever is the more
you acronym eyesee it the more boring
you make it the less likely you are to
the people are to pay attention to it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net